Lauren bobert is pleading the blood of
Jesus to try to win her race what the
hell am I talking about I don't even
know let me reset the stage there are
there is a triumvirate of Maga people
one of whom has already lost I'm talking
about Marjorie Taylor green Madison
cawthorne Lauren bober these three are
sort of like emblematic they are the
prototypical whacked out Maga candidates
that don't have any business being in
the House of Representatives Marjorie
Taylor green easily won re-election on
Tuesday
however Madison cawthorne lost his
Republican primary months ago and is
being removed after just one term Lauren
bobert is number three and indeed she
may lose when we go and take a look at
Colorado and we look at that Third
District you will see that as of this
moment Adam Frisch the Democratic
Challenger is 64 votes ahead of Lauren
bober that is a razor thin margin
we don't yet know for sure who will win
but what we have been told is that the
remaining ballots that five percent of
the vote that is outstanding favors Adam
Frisch and that it is plausible while
certainly not a guarantee that Lauren
bobert would be defeated here is
something really wacky and I don't even
know what this means Lauren bobert said
that they are pleading the blood of
Jesus to try to win this was at the end
of her event on Tuesday night at which
point her confidence level was a little
lower than it was at the start of the
night that's for sure
[Music]
people they are so precious God we plead
the blood over our elections father God
I thank you there's a hedge of
protection I thank you God for
everything that you are doing I don't
know what it means to plead the blood of
Jesus I genuinely don't know what that
is that a good thing or is it a bad
thing
[Music]
well if it doesn't matter then I don't
even know why bobert is running but
that's maybe a question for a different
day
is there something wrong with me that
I'm enjoying seeing her uh potentially
lose and and just lose it in this way is
that something that I should be
exploring in therapy that I'm taking
such pleasure in her potential
Misfortune or is it logical given how
horrible and humiliating a person she is
earlier in the night she was much more
confident she said it was all trending
in her Direction but judging from the
Applause it's not even really clear the
crowd believed it but I am so optimistic
yeah it is absolutely trending in our
favor as Ben has told you the New York
Times is still saying congresswoman
Lauren bober is very likely to win
now the truth is the New York Times
stopped updating those predictive uh
tools that they had a few hours into the
night and it was really worth nothing at
that point in time I don't want to
celebrate too early because Lauren
bobert may win but if indeed some of the
analysts who really know Colorado are
right who are looking county by county
if indeed she does lose it will be a
great thing in all likelihood and again
when we look at the numbers if we go
back from Colorado
and we go to the map right now you need
218 seats to control the House of
Representatives right now Democrats have
191 and Republicans have 209 it is still
definitely the most likely outcome that
Republicans will control the house but
controlling it with Lauren bobert and
Madison cawthorne both losing their
first turn after their first terms is a
much better scenario and when we
consider that triumvirate green
cawthorne bobert removing two-thirds of
it is a beautiful thing we're going to
take a very quick break we have a packed
program for you today
one of our sponsors today is blue chew a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as Viagra and
Cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month's supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence when
it's time all you have to do is take a
short quiz on their website a licensed
doctor approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discrete package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of Bluetooth tablets are made in the
USA the entire process is just a few
clicks go to bluetooth.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code Pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping